all of us are dead isn't that a fact season
two episode two guys if you could hit that
like button would very much appreciate it helps
us out in the algorithm he's trying to get in
that dos cavazos feed you know anywho subscribe
and click that notification bell hopefully we'll
wind up in that get jaby feed after that hey
check us out on patreon massive thanks to all
who have become superjects today by checking out
all that crap we got to offer over there hopefully
i'm not following other reactors who are
covering this and uh thanks to the boys
of prepper for helping us edit these down
you guys are okay gentlemen let's get to it
meanwhile i'll take the coat
off use the cone as a weapon
keep calm everybody
oh thank god he had that cone
oh he saved her good good
oh my goodness oh she's turning she
damn that is some amazing zombie acting
wow
oh my god why can't one person
bite him this guy of all people
oh god
are they on the roof
or is the no the roof is higher okay
this is crazy there's nowhere to run
blast them do it i imagine something different
well the amount of people fighting this one room
insane this is where the resistance will begin
good timing
oh no competition
oh good now i can get out of the world
i bet at that school they're like we
need to keep this an internal matter
really really be careful as to how
he did turn his son intentionally
called him right away
oh my god at least he caught this in 4k yeah
dude you created the first zombie
virus come on that's something
yourself a little credit
you brought fiction to life
get in there expose your neck
oh are you doing this to yourself
it's trying to busan
oh wow that is so fun
wow
oh really smart
it's a good try though oh no they're
gonna think it's a prank called
now come hose down the zombies
you know it's okay to call with
like a bit of panic in your voice to
literally alert them to the violence
that's occurring in your school
now we gotta keep up the social
show ready for that way more
barricade the door why didn't we think
yeah you know all these like
rules about council and student
nah man that's what keeps us sane is this [ __ ]
oh my god guys cut his head off guys
bash his head as he in train to busan
oh jesus
oh no
just just cut the lower half
of your face off you'll be fine
oh i just met you and i
already don't want you to die
you don't all have to leave just
get a couple of them out yeah
dude what is it oh you are
we thought you had it covered man
go man do your thing
watch your hands
my dude's been waiting for this day
oh that's where the answers
are yeah defeat it with science
fire extinguisher is coming in clutch today
oh no
oh [ __ ]
that's right i broke it
don't break more windows what are you doing
i mean i know you're panicked but still
let me have a shot everybody
take turns going shifts
i keep playing out a scenario in
my head where they could have just
lured out the other two and
they could have kept that room
oh now he's on a solo journey
he's like the wreck of the show he's gonna
come back with a beard and a son carl carl carl
man you are the worst
i like her yeah she's the badass this
ensemble just keeps getting bigger and
bigger it's gonna be the whole city by the end
of the show another school in another school
oh
would have done the trick
how's your chance don't wait for her to run at
you yeah come on okay wait for her to run are you
oh my god
oh
is contact your parents
good speech teach ah man stud
muffins out there somewhere
she's bleeding isn't she
oh i really liked her yeah i did too
oh that's so sad
we're gonna have to throw you out a window
oh
you gotta have glass in your gut now
she was awesome
why don't you grab something to grab
a little bit of a like a piece of wood
hey perfect
damn it that's annoying
chocolate
decide everything with rock paper scissors
be a lot harder climbing up huh yeah
half of them are going to fall
my
me
just tell her
holy am so worried this
guy's not gonna make it man
you're the most priceless work of art in this room
ugh
no
you gotta be [ __ ] me tell
me one of them broke his fall
that is so frustrating
that is so frustrating yeah
although we didn't see it happen not
that i think that matters in this
show but he didn't see it happen
so you never know you never know
where would he have landed no idea there's
nothing really that i can think of none of the
shrubs below look strong enough to break a fall
from that height without causing serious damage
i think if he was able to grab the hose then
he would have splattered against the wall
but yeah that sucks yeah that's that painful
that's annoying yeah genuinely annoyed
yeah like dude come on for situations exactly
like this you tell her wait you're annoyed that
he didn't tell her how you felt that's what you
were thinking i mean not really i was more like
if they didn't waste any time if she if
she would just got on that rope earlier
he would have been going down that rope yeah
that's true absolutely damn you're grieving
damn you having to process the loss of your
best friend how dare you yeah there's just
two it's like everything changed in the split
of just a few seconds when it was like i'll go
first no you go first and then they debated
about that like there's no time for debating
those seconds cost him that's so frustrating so
annoying how a few seconds would have changed
everything yeah unless he comes back and he's
alive in the next episode again i don't expect
it and i feel like it would be really hard
to explain that in a way that doesn't kind of
undercut things but at the same time we didn't
see it happen so i just i've learned never to
never to put too much talk into a
death i didn't actually get to watch
that was uh that was sad it was a good one it was
real tense tight episode it was an hour over an
hour long but it flew by pretty fast because it
was just the zombie thrills you got a good oner
at the top at the cafeteria which was cool
to behold very visceral intense disgusting
in all the right ways wet yeah water and blood
love it lick it up keep referencing the raid but
it again reminded me of that prison fight a little
bit it's like how how wet you feel watching it
yeah it was good man it was really well
done um i think i know some of the casts
i mean that one girl is in squid game for
sure yeah that's her character squid game
uh your character's background
is you're in squid gear
hey i mean everyone's wearing that similar shade
of green uh you know i mean uh i forget the names
i call them stud muffin stuff muffin
yeah repressed boy who just died
girl interest best friend of girl squid game
game i don't know any other the characters uh
good lady who is the teacher this park i
know that's either one remember miss park
this badass girl in the bathroom yeah then
we got that [ __ ] and oh badass girl in the
bathroom she was awesome she was really a badass
for sure so i'll be killing i loved her attitude
the whole time yeah it's just cold but you know
she's fighting the right fight and she knows how
to fight i like the introduction of the archers
too that was wicked yeah i forgot they set that up
i think what they're doing slowly is they're
throwing not slowly but quite fast actually
it's throwing you into the peril so much and uh
you know this outbreak of just the this hive mind
of all kinds of this cacophony of just [ __ ]
and then they're introducing slowly people who
you can root for to help save the day yeah stud
muffin archers archers which is cool smoker lady
so you have like those kind of badass characters
who can really hold their own they did establish
in stud muffin though in the last episode how
like he doesn't fight anymore and he would give
up all the fighting that meant but damn this guy
knows how to fight he's actually secretly 40 years
old it has black belts in every elite style of
fighting sometimes this uh there's something about
the quality of this show that i really appreciate
which is they know what zombies are they they've
they've been made privy to it through works of
fiction and now they're experienced in real life
so what the show does as an audience
member is challenge logic and reasoning
in times when you're like but i'm not in their
shoes so i'd probably make some stupid choices
too oh yeah and it's of a panic all of that
armchair logic of why don't you just do this yeah
it goes out the window it's really easy for me to
imagine doing a john wick type of takedown against
an army of men but then i'm like ah but if i had
to kill a guy i don't know if i could actually
do it you know so it's the kind of thing where i'm
like i want to yell at the people and then i go
it's because they know what zombies are so i want
to like kind of yell at them and then i like ah
but you know you can't you can't really blame
bunch of teenagers for having to deal with
death in front of their faces and then like you
can't like especially before someone's turned
and there's even that part of you that i thought
they handled really well with that friend's death
that goes uh they turn but maybe there's a
chance they did go back you know organizing of
these happy movies yeah or maybe it's not gonna
affect you as bad as it affected everybody else
yeah it's like when it's someone you care a
lot about you you hope you can break through
to them you know and i like i so i like that i
do because like the classroom scene at the top
or the first place they huddled together i did
find myself like getting frustrated at like
just get the two people out it's not that it's
much easier than this hallway door thing you got
going on inject it then i go oh no but you're
in a situation like that you probably want to
like does it get the water this isn't safe in here
um yeah so you got that or even being trapped in
there and wanting to get the fire hose like yes
things like that or i have a really squid game
ladies gonna piss me the [ __ ] off as a shooter
she just seems like she just yells at people yeah
just like i'm not really doing anything but
i'm gonna yell you're not doing something yeah
i'm gonna be rate everybody around for not being
competent while i just make everything worse she
really seems like she's going to get on my nerves
yeah and get a lot of other people killed probably
probably she's the kind of would throw you
in front of someone absolutely she would
and then you got the hospital thing too that's
crazy we're like watching the journey of this one
woman this one zombie woman who like infected the
school and now she's infecting the hospital then
she's gonna go to a church and then she's going to
go to a mcdonald's and the starbucks she's going
to slide their party to all these places concert
hall protect all of south korea yeah and then move
on to other areas of asia eastern europe there's
one woman doing everything well that's what i i
really like is is yeah it's like you don't really
leave the school much but you do for crucial
little moments like that and they've tied a lot
of the elements together really nice like yeah i
like that they have a certain amount of awareness
so that when that scene comes around where they
actually call the police station i thought that
was handled pretty conscientiously work first
you know you have the trope of zombie up well
that's in public ah we're gonna laugh about this
and then the hospital call comes in and lends
it credence and i thought that was like really
nicely handled of like wait some shit's going down
to the hospital somebody's biting people zombies
uh and and just the way that they like these two
episodes yeah they have that thing where it's
like you're watching essentially just a series of
zombie movies as a season of tv but at the same
time what this feels like it's doing is re this
feels like it's taking place in very real time
uh which i feel like is one of the most unique
aspects of it like it doesn't seem like we're
hopping around almost at all in terms of the point
from which we started you know we saw a little bit
of a flashback in the first episode but like since
it has hit the school it's pretty much just been
where do we go next you know well school settings
cool yeah that's a really cool setting to have
this at yeah it's a great containment spot you
know i think sometimes the best zombie movies are
ones that are just a locked off location where
they're trapped but it's big enough where you can
run around still explore different locations
how do we get from this floor to that floor
you know i think it's smart
smart stuff to toy with
but man that phone call thing kind of aggravated
me yeah he's like why are you calling in such a
calm manner yeah just be like don't like scream
there are people murdering people that are there
to say that there's a riot of people who are
biting and swiping at people calling father
firefighting dad like just say that yeah
there's like oh there's riots and there's
people being murdered if you're if you like
come to your senses and go we can't say zombies
and your second call infuse the packs people
take your situation seriously there is a crisis
and my voice denotes the crisis well what what
was i think frustrating about it is it didn't seem
like uh authentic within the moment how that
call was handled because i'm like nah they'd
probably panic you know a little bit although
they'd probably have like anxiety while they're
making this call right yeah and then
like it's already a big deal when they're
teenagers were having to call the cops because
they didn't they didn't their anxiety wasn't
piercing through their call and so that's why i
was like what a weird acting choice it just seemed
like it was like that for the comedy yeah and
then to have her on the other end be like don't
say zombie they're not gonna believe that like
it doesn't and you know there's maybe it sounds
more urgent if you could actually speak korean but
yeah it did sound a little bit like you know why
hey we could sound more credible yeah it sounded
like a prank call it almost felt like yeah they
had it sound less urgent to lend you know credence
to the guy's reaction which isn't the best choice
yes right out of a whole hour and ten minutes
that's the takeaway that's all that's what's
important we got from it remember one minute right
there oh oh and what's going on i'm excited to see
what horrible fate befalls the scoundrel guy who's
still in the cafeteria or whatever that horrible
[ __ ] penis i know like 10 zombies are gonna
like one zombie's gonna bite onto his penis and
then like one each on his butt cheeks and then you
know it's gonna tear him apart from the bottom up
he sucks yeah he's a terrible character that's you
know what's that you feed the woman to the zombies
and that's like now you just kind of
made your presence more of an alert
of where you're hiding yeah exactly are
you gonna throw her across like really
you should have thrown one of
those watermelons or something
um i don't get how they're hiding so well there
yeah it seems pretty exposed i mean unless it's
like all the water or something is getting in
the way of the zombie smelling them as much but
i don't know that's just me thinking about
it and science dad what a science dad man
it's not going well in interrogation traded all
for his son to stand up against bullies that's
right man that's how this began bullying's a real
problem not just in the united states of america
but across the world well suicide girl at the top
deck man i mean she's like freaking they got the
best hideout and she gets to watch the everyone
fall yeah oh what a great to watch everyone burn
she can be she could be the devil in hell just
watching everyone burn oh man what a great view of
like especially when you hate everyone yeah
yeah his friends from seats to the massacre
that's good for her yeah man i mean you know
she's earned that yeah she's earned the right
to sit around and watch the world crumble i'm
not trying to be a hero in a situation like this
look out for myself and only myself that's
good i don't know i feel like he would do
well in a zombie apocalypse especially
with those crucial elements of time
yeah i'd really utilize my time management you
would that would be the key as to why you're a
perfect person for the zombie survival squad
is because you would keep everybody on track
you come and be like hey we can't argue about
this [ __ ] for too long otherwise all of us are
going to die one of us is going to die we could
prevent this and just [ __ ] go yeah man yeah
don't mess with me you know always on a clock yeah
man come in handy in the apocalypse the apocalypse
look out yeah for those who made it this far
that's first all right guys let's do a page
eric horstmann i didn't even check to see if
you're still pledged for the month of february
i'm just assuming you're still pledged for the
month of february if you're not pledged for
the month of february i'm going into the youtube
editor and i'm deleting this straight up stricken
from the record years of being our one of our
highest pledged patrons won't count for [ __ ] no
you think we're just gonna give you a shout out
out of the kindness of our hearts if i open up
the pledge manager and go this guy on pledge for
the first time in a few years wow you know after
that whole load of money millions of dollars
he's given us not no freebies around here
no shout out what have you done for me lately
that's what i think you are as good as the
last thing you did the last pledge i don't i
don't factor in most any of what you've done
i look at a singular last name not collective
it's not the quality of your character it's the
content of your patreon pledge so eric um here's
hoping that this shout out counts for something
i think you would uh be frustrating and apocalypse
to be honest it would be you would be fun if we
were really secure but the rest of the time
i think uh i i think you might get us killed
if anyone's going to pick a fight amongst the
group is probably but you know it'll be uh bring
up like other matters and subjects that are like
this isn't pertinent to do the moment right now
man we gotta focus on surviving society has
long since crumbled okay but either way uh
yeah you know be nice to have you around happy
february go uh order a male prostitute to
split it up so that way youtube kind of
detects what i'll say yeah male prostate